- This program is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
non-commercial use only.
(upbeat techno music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is the 2008
Hitchcock professor at Berkeley.
Leon Lederman is an
internationally renowned scientist
for his work on neutrinos,
ghost-like particles
that pass through
everything in the universe.
Among his many honors are the Wolf Prize
in Physics in 1982.
And in 1988, along with Melvin Schwartz
and Jack Steinberger, he won
the Nobel Prize in physics
for his discovery of the muon neutrino
proving they're at least
two families of neutrinos.
He's a founder and resident scholar
at the Illinois mathematics
and Science Academy,
Director Emeritus of the Fermilab,
and Pritzker professor of science
at the Illinois Institute of Technology.
For many years he was the
Eugene Higgins professor
of physics at Columbia,
and then the Frank Salzburger professor
of physics at the University of Chicago.
Professor Lederman, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you.
- Where were you born and raised?
- New York City.
- And looking back, how do you think
your parents shaped your
thinking about the world?
- That's an interesting question.
Well, fundamentally, I think
they had a big role in this
because they were hard working.
They were free thinkers.
My father varied in his political leanings
depending on who was doing
what, and who was saying what.
So he wasn't rigid in all of this.
And both of them were intensely
interested in education,
especially my education.
We lived within about two
or three hundred yards
from a high school.
I remember asking my parents
about the possibility.
At that time Bronx High School of Science,
famous school, didn't exist.
But there was the best high school
in New York City was Stuyvesant.
It's still a great high school.
And I asked my mother
about the possibility
of my going to Stuyvesant.
And her answer was, can
you walk to Stuyvesant?
And I said, oh, no, you
have to take a subway.
She says, well, you can walk to
this high school we live near.
We moved here so that you
could walk to high school.
It's James Monroe High School,
and that's where you're going.
And that's where I went.
- So it was an exciting
time to be in New York City.
And then the important role
that science was playing
as a result of World War II and after.
I'm very curious about
how you were drawn in
as a high school kid, young person,
into the culture of science, basically.
What were the formative early experiences
that got you interested--
- Well, it was the classes.
The classes were taught by
extremely competent teachers.
And that was the drawing
features that I took.
First, I was fascinated by
chemistry and drawn into that.
And there was a young man who was
working his way through night school,
but he worked in the
laboratory with glassware
and taught me how to blow glass
and shape the various
devices that you need to make
in order to filter and
precipitate various things.
So I was charmed by the
chemistry initially,
and the teaching of chemistry
by the high school teacher.
And then a little bit later, physics.
And when I was absolutely overwhelmed
by the lectures we had in physics,
- This is in high school now.
- This is all in high school.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, and so the high school
experience was first rate.
And there was also writing
exercises and creative writing.
I remember going into a
class of creative writers
where the teacher would tell
us how to organize words
and expressions into something,
which is a little different
from standard expressions.
So I had a good education.
And our fellow students
were part of that education.
We talked to each other about
the school work very often,
and argued politics and things like that.
- What was the attitude
towards science at that time
better than it is today, and therefore,
there was a heroic quality
to being a scientist?
- I'm not sure we could
have defined attitude.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- But really, it was one of the subjects.
And we didn't have a yes or a no opinion.
Science was interesting,
sometimes difficult,
sometimes too easy.
We took it as it was given to us.
We were not aware of the crucial role
that science played in society.
I mean, in school at that time,
and unfortunately, too often today,
you spend most of your time
on the content of science
but not on the significance of it,
the process of science.
Who becomes a scientist?
We didn't think of ourselves
as becoming scientists.
We were interested in science.
I guess it was the laboratory
work was fascinating,
and every once in a while
something would go kaboom.
And that was exciting.
(laughs)
- Were you a tinkerer?
Did you like to do experiments?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Yes, actually, I had an older brother
who later turned out to
be a high school drop-out.
But he had magic hands.
He could do things with his hands.
He could make things.
And my greatest joy was in watching him.
And so, when it came to
the household chores,
I would do mine, and I would do his
just because if I did his chores
he would let me watch him in the basement
working with chemicals and stuff
he got from the drug store,
occasionally chemistry O3
or some set of chemical experiments.
He loved to tinker in that way.
And I loved to watch him.
- Where did you do your
undergraduate work,
and then what year was that?
- Well, I started, let's see,
City College of New York,
and in '39.
Graduated in '43.
So that was my four years of City College.
And City College was
available by street car
(laughs) from my house, changing twice.
- You were old enough
to get on the subway.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
Well, it wasn't the subway.
It was the surface transportation.
- And then you serviced in the military?
- Well, that came later.
I was inducted into the Army in '43.
Almost didn't graduate.
And was in the Army for three years.
- And then, graduate work,
where did you do your graduate work?
- I did my graduate work at Columbia.
I got into Columbia University
when I was discharged from the Army.
First thing I did was to
register as a physics major.
I had switched interest
from chemistry to physics
somewhere in the inner room.
I thought physics was more challenging,
and in fact, in many ways,
simpler than chemistry.
And it didn't have the smells.
And it didn't have the
(laughing)
tribulations of sweeping up the materials
you dropped on the floor,
and getting the wrong
answer on the analysis
of what mysterious stuff was there.
But physics was a challenge.
And that was when I really thought about
a career in science.
- And in graduate school,
any particular professors
who mentored you,
and who became your
dissertation advisor, and so on?
- Well, let's see.
The physics department at
Columbia was chaired by
Isidor Isaac Rabi, one of the
founders of American physics.
He on the East Coast
and Robert Oppenheimer on the West Coast,
really started the American
schools of physics.
And they were helped
by lots of immigration.
And in fact, at Columbia,
Rabi had invited a
particular rather well-known
cosmic ray expert by the
name of Gilberto Bernardini.
And so I tell a lot of
stories about Gilberto
because he came from Italy with a rather
severe war time experience,
and we got to know each other.
And his command of English
was limited but enough.
And we got to be very friendly.
And I think he was a major
element in my education
because he'd been an
experienced cosmic ray scientist
and knew how to do research.
But he was also different.
He was so different from the
Anglo-Saxon professors I had.
He was passionate and excitable.
And the thing he taught me that I think
was the most important
was his sense of wonder.
He'd walk into a room and
push the light button.
The lights would go on.
He'd say, fantastico!
That's Italian.
It means fantastic.
(chuckles)
And then he would turn the lights off,
and turn 'em on again, turn
'em off, turn 'em on again.
He was amazed by simple things.
If you asked him how did it happen?
Well, he would say, behind
the switch there's a contact.
Then the contact closes a circuit.
And somewhere 100 miles away
water is falling on a wheel
and turning, and making the electricity.
He would know all that.
But for him, the idea that
this is a button on the wall,
and you push it, and the
lights go on, was a miracle.
And never tired of being
awed by simple things.
- And that's really
something that you picked up.
And I guess, that's an
important ingredient
in being a scientist, of maintaining that.
- I think it's crucial.
I mean, the sense of wonder
and the sense of understanding something
after working at it a long time,
or the since of discovering
how something works
when you first look at
it it's total mystery.
You can make a discovery as a scientist,
an important discovery,
once in a lifetime,
maybe two or three times if you're
very, very fortunate and very clever.
But the daily process of doing science
has to bring you some satisfaction too.
You just can't wait for the discovery,
and wait for the fame, and so on.
You have to enjoy the day-to-day
activities in some sense.
And that's what I learned from Bernardini.
- And let's explore that some more.
An important component in the culture
and the attitudes of a scientist
is really being very curious,
wanting to know what is this
made of, how does it work?
- Well, there's a list of
qualities that go into science,
and one of them is curiosity.
Another one is open-mindedness.
But as somebody wise-cracked,
not so open that your brain falls out.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- And then the pursuit
of answers to questions.
If you're curious you wanna
know why this happened.
You've got to take some joy
in the day-to-day processes.
Most of the time, you're developing tools.
I was more interested
in experimental science
than theoretical science.
And so, being familiar with tools
and getting them to work
was part of the daily grind.
- A lot of frustration
in that daily grind?
- Oh, sure, sure.
- Things break?
- Things break.
They don't work.
You make stupid mistakes.
Your elbow knocks over
a flask of something,
some gook that (laughing)
you shouldn't have dropped.
There's all kinds of disappointments
that go into science,
especially if you're kind of clumsy.
And I was probably among the more clumsy
of the experimental scientist.
- There seems to be this interplay
as you become socialized into science
of knowing where the work is,
where the important problems are.
So developing experience in that regard.
And on the other hand, being creative
and sort of looking at something anew.
Talk a little about that tension
between experience and creativity.
- Oh, it's tough.
It's tough.
Creativity is something
we talk a lot about,
especially in the search
for graduate students,
or even in your dealing
with high school students
once in a while.
And creativity is a
property you wish you had
this kind of magic paper.
You put it to the tongue of the student,
and if it turns orange he's creative.
But there's no measurement of creativity.
You can find kids who are
excellent at solving problems.
They can do all the problems
in the back of the book.
They can get good grades on exams.
But creativity is a more subtle thing.
It's very hard to predict creativity
unless you spend a lot
of time with a student,
and you begin to see how
the student's mind works
when it comes to certain problems.
And when the student says something
that you don't understand,
and little by little you grasp
what the student is getting at.
And even though his
articulation may be poor,
you suddenly see his thinking.
He's got an idea, and he
or she may be creative.
Creativity is a subtle thing.
And of course, in your
own pursuit of science,
sometimes you'll wake up
at three in the morning
with an idea.
And then you want to record it.
You might forget it.
Is it a good idea?
Well, we'll see what it
looks like in the morning.
Sometimes you get an idea,
and you don't even wanna
think about the idea
because more often than not
the idea you think is good
turns out to be a flop.
A soon as you explain
it to your colleague,
or your professor, or someone,
they say, oh, that doesn't work.
And more often than not,
that's what happens with ideas.
But from time to time, the idea will live.
And you get more courage
about it with time,
and eventually you have enough nerve
to broach it to your colleagues.
And they will, of course,
start throwing blackboard
erasers at you, and chalk.
And saying, that's crazy.
Go away.
But you stick with it, and
ultimately, you can sell it.
And then suddenly, your team has
a pursuit that's very interesting.
- And so, what I'm
hearing you say is that,
also another tension
between self-confidence,
and arrogance, and being
comfortable with your own ideas,
running with them.
But then on the other
hand, working with teams
to move the idea forward.
- That's crucial.
I mean, and especially
in experimental science,
where you really have to work with people.
A, to get financial support.
B, to get equipment together.
C, just the sheer effort
of getting an experiment
together requires collaboration.
So collaborative research
is how I grew up.
Really is being crucial is to
get people to work with you,
whether they're students or
colleagues, usually both,
is an important part of the whole issue.
That means you have to be convincing.
I've got an idea.
Oh, come on.
But you keep persisting,
and eventually you get a discussion going.
And maybe they'll say, yeah,
yeah, it is a good idea.
Or they'll say, it would be a good idea,
but you forgot the following principle.
And so that interaction
with your colleagues
is a very important part of science.
- You focused in your
work on particle physics.
How did you come to that field?
And help us understand what
it is and why it's important.
- Well, I must say that,
we're now talking 1950,
and particle physics was a
new subject in some sense.
And we didn't know we were
breaking in a new subject,
but we were working with
the properties of matter.
You look at a piece of wood,
and you can splinter it,
and you being to realize
the chemical composition,
and then you go beyond
the chemical composition
of the material into detail properties.
We were in a field in which
the atom was an old story.
Atomic physics was thriving,
but we knew the properties of atoms.
But there were other things that happened
that had to do with production of energy
and mostly in machines.
So there were particle accelerators.
We had a Columbia, thanks
to the efforts of Rabi,
built, at that time, was one
of the world's most powerful
newspapers called an Atom Smasher.
We keep saying, we don't smash atoms.
We love atoms.
(laughing)
But this was a way of generating
a lot energy into a small space.
And because of that energy,
particles would appear
via Einstein's famous
equation, E=mc squared,
energy and mass were connected.
And by producing a lot of
energy with this machine
we could create new masses,
and study those masses,
and begin to get a vision
and an understanding
of the microstructure of matter.
In other words, what's
inside is the key thing.
So what's inside the atom?
Well, there's a nucleus.
And then there are
electrons on the outside.
What's inside the nucleus?
Well, there are protons and neutrons.
And we continued that process.
It was called reductionist, if you like.
We wanted to reduce the
properties of matter
to their simplest forms,
and then see how these
simple forms combine
to make the more complicated things,
which we recognize as quantitative matter.
And again, it's a combination
of energy and imagination,
sprinkled with a little bit of good luck.
And all of a sudden you found the particle
that nobody knew existed.
- And ultimately, this
really moves into cosmology
to answer questions about
how it all came into being.
- Well, that's a good statement
because, in fact, today
we have a new subject
that's called particle astrophysics.
It turns out that our study
of the structure of matter
turned out to be crucial
to the larger picture
of the structure of the universe.
Planets we knew about
because we live on one.
And so we were experienced.
But then there were galaxies
and millions of suns,
each son having its share
of planets around them.
And so the two subjects, in fact,
turned out to be very closely related.
And when I became director of Fermilab,
the first thing I did was to create
a group of astrophysicist,
even though the lab
itself was the repository
of one of the largest
accelerators in the world.
And that accelerator is
like a big microscope.
So you can look at the small.
But at the same time, we knew that
if you're going to try
to understand the cosmos
you have to have a good knowledge of
the fundamental structures.
So particles in cosmology
became a unified quest.
Very exciting and still is.
- Help us understand what
you and your colleagues
got the Nobel Prize for.
Can you, if I sit here and introduce you
and say that you did
important work with neutrinos,
people out there are scratching
their head and so on.
- Well, it's a bit of a story.
We cataloged the various particles.
And then electron was
an important particle.
It had an electric charge.
It had a certain mass.
We measured the properties of
the electron in great detail
that was discovered in 1890 something.
And the properties of the
electron were viewed upon
for the next hundred years to
know more and more about it.
We then also discovered radioactivity,
and the processes by which spontaneously
particles would explode
and give rise to lesser mass particles.
And one of those particles was a neutrino.
It was named, of course, by Enrico Fermi,
because it had an Italian sound.
(Italian accent)
Neutrino.
It literally, the small neutral one.
And these neutrinos were
produced in radioactivity.
And then it turned out
that there was a puzzle
in the properties of the neutrino
that we thought was
pretty well understood.
Wherever you had radioactivity,
you have the emission of neutrinos.
And then we actually, at that time,
and looking at some of these
processes were very puzzled.
And eventually, the puzzle was clarified
by the assumption that there were
two different kinds of neutrinos.
One kind related closely to the electron,
and the other kind,
that was the new thing,
related to a cousin of the
electron called a muon.
And so, our prize was given for
the discovery of the muon neutrino.
And so there were two
families of neutrinos.
One related to the electron.
One related to the muon,
which is a heavy cousin of the electron.
Now we know.
Had we known then,
maybe they wouldn't
have given us the prize.
But there are in fact
three kinds of neutrinos.
There's one related to the electron,
one related to the muon,
and one related to the tau.
Nevermind.
(laughing)
You don't wanna go into that much detail.
But we essentially clarified
the structure of neutrinos
by means of this muon type neutrino.
And that involved using the
most powerful accelerator.
And producing essentially
a stream of radioactivity
and a wall about 20 feet thick,
which stopped all
radioactivity except neutrinos,
which were very penetrating.
We know, for example, that
right now we're sitting here,
and somewhere if it's
after 10 o'clock at night,
there are neutrinos coming from the sun,
which is on the other
side of the planet Earth
and pouring through the
Earth, very penetrating.
Coming through us, and then
going on off somewhere.
So the electron neutrino
properties was sort of known.
And then now we had
another kind of neutrino,
which we call a muon neutrino,
which in all of it's reactions
was associated with
this muon type particle.
So that structure became clear
as a result of our experiments.
And the King of Sweden was
very curious about this
and sent for us.
And there was a great party.
I recommend it highly.
- This is the Nobel Prize now.
- Yes, that's right.
- And I think I read
somewhere that you said
that you had Swedish holy
water sprinkled on you.
- That's another way of talking about it.
- I'm curious, how long was
the experiment in preparation?
I mean, what was the lead
up time to actually saying,
we need to do this, and
then implementing the--
- I think it was a couple of years.
This was '59 to '61 we did the experiment.
And by '61 we had clarified this.
But the committee are slow readers, so.
(laughing)
And there were so many
good things happening
in science in those
days that it took to 80,
I guess '88 when we were
actually awarded the prize
and had our trip to Sweden.
- And so you do the experiment,
and then is there like a
wow moment at that time?
Talk about the fruits of your labor
and you're experiencing,
is it a moment or does it take
longer to analyze the data?
Yeah.
- It's a series of moments.
You set up the equipment,
and in this particular case, and you wait.
And I remember once, it usually happens
at three in the morning
or something like that.
You're watching the apparatus,
and suddenly the apparatus is telling you
something happened.
And you look at the data, and you see that
a particle appears and makes a collusion.
And out of that collusion
comes some energy,
and the energy goes a certain
distance and then stops.
And when you analyze that,
the only thing it could be
is a neutrino type particle,
which disintegrated
and gave rise to a muon
rather than an electron.
So this was, whereas all
the neutrinos before this
were related to electrons,
we had succeeded in making a stream
of different kinds of neutrinos,
which were related to the muon.
We checked this, and rechecked
it, and rechecked it,
and finally, we were convinced that
this a different kind of neutrino.
And we announced it, and published it,
ang gave a lot of talks
all over the place.
This was in the early 60s.
And then went on to many, many
other kinds of experiments.
But eventually, the Nobel committee
came to this particular discovery.
A lot of Nobel Prizes really
require more information
than just the experiment
that makes the discovery.
It has to be in a context.
And what happened was, a
structure of fundamental particles
was beginning to take shape.
And knowing the existence
of a muon neutrino
was crucial to building that structure.
And so, that's when the prize was awarded.
- And so, it's not just the
recognition of the Nobel,
but it's the recognition over time
of the fellow scientist
of what you have done.
- That's right.
It fit into a pattern.
And the pattern became clarified
by that experiment as so.
- Now, being able to do this, obviously,
required these accelerators,
which in a way were a major investment
by the government presumably,
and also by Columbia University.
So talk a little about that
because in this recent period
there has been a decline
of that commitment to funding big science,
but that was not the case
when you were able to do this.
- Well, I think there's a pattern.
I mean, the structure
of elementary particles
is now very largely understood.
It's called the standard model.
And so it's a little
bit like in chemistry.
There's something that decorates the walls
of all the chemistry
classes around the planet.
And that's called the periodic
table of the elements.
So you have hydrogen
here, and helium here,
and you have all the hundred
or so chemical elements.
And knowing that, that's the
battle flag of chemistry.
That's the whole subject of chemistry
is involved with that periodic table.
Well, we have a different periodic table
at a scale much, much finer
than the chemical scale,
and that is the fundamental particles.
And we now know that the neutrino,
there's the standard model has
electrons, muons, and taus,
leptons, and then it has
the heaver particles,
the strange quarks, the charm
quark, the strange quark,
and in a pattern.
And that's like a periodic table.
In other words, everything we have,
everything we know about in matter
is composed of various
components of that standard model
providing you know not only the
properties of the particles,
but their social behavior.
How does the muon behave
compared to the tau?
Or how does a top quark behave
compared to the bottom quark?
We have these funny names for things.
But the standard model is a
very powerful summary of nature.
And we're (chuckles), I could
say we're charmed by this
because there's a charm quark too.
But today we're left
with this standard model
and some very, very mysterious puzzles.
So I think, and hopefully,
we try to, in the U.S.,
to build a particle accelerator
that would address these puzzles.
It was canceled by congress in 1993
for reasons which are complicated
and probably not worth going into.
And then the Europeans led in
the construction of a new accelerator.
And the U.S. and all
the other major nations
contributed to this.
So it's a world collaboration.
It's being built in Switzerland.
And it turned on six or seven months ago,
and then had some difficulties.
And we expect it to start up again
and within the next few months.
And yeah, it'll take another year or so
to become familiar with this huge machine,
very huge, very expensive machine.
But the whole world of industrial nations
that are interested in science
have contributed to this.
So we expect that some of
our puzzles will be solved
when this machine really gets going
and begins to explore parts of nature
that have not yet been explored.
- But before we talk about your work
in trying to transform science
education for young people,
I have a question because an
important period in your career
is you were director of the Fermilab.
And I'm curious about
what from that experience
you learned about organizing bit science.
Because as we face challenges
such as the environment and so on,
we're gonna have to be thinking about
science at the strategic level.
Do you have any insights that
come from that experience?
- A lot.
I mean, this is big science.
I other words, it's big expensive science.
It involves large machines.
We're comfortable with the notion that
when we do big science,
there are byproducts of this
that are societally very beneficial.
And so, there are many, many examples
where the quest for
understanding in an abstract way
gives rise to very useful offshoots
and a broadening of our
deep knowledge of things,
which have to do almost anything
you wanna do with human activity.
So we're confident that
research pays, in some sense,
even though it may sound
to be very abstract.
Yet, today, if you got up on a platform
and said, we really have
to build some xyz machine,
you would probably be ushered out
because this is a time of economic chaos
and environmental catastrophe,
and all kinds of problems
we have, health care,
many, many issues that
our government is facing
that require a lot of attention.
Nevertheless, in spite of that,
many of us feel that ultimately
both science and education
are essential features
in getting out of this problem.
Because if you make a
list of all the problems
that our president is facing
and that our congress is facing
and make a list, you begin to see that
addressing those problems is gonna require
scientific knowledge, scientific wisdom,
engineering wisdom, and understanding.
So we can't give up on our quest for
understanding of how nature works,
and the process of
understanding the world.
And then today, there are some mysteries
that come from the thing you
raised earlier, the cosmology.
Cosmology, there's a.
At Fermilab when I was a director
I started a cosmology group,
and it became one of the more
powerful groups in the nation,
in which cosmology plays a
role in the macroscopic world
of galaxies of trillions and
trillions of miles across
to the microscopic world
of sub-nuclear particles.
It's the big and the small
combined in many ways.
And so, we're very anxious
to continue our research.
We don't wanna stop research
because there are too many things
that will come out of
it that will be useful.
And of course, direct research on
environmental energy sources is crucial.
We know that many things,
we know what to do,
and other things we don't know what to do.
And so, we just let curiosity play a role,
and we follow that in the best way we can.
- Let's talk now about the
need to revise the curriculum
to change our public
schools so we can create
another generation of
scientists like yours.
You're a critic of the current curriculum.
What's wrong with it,
and what are the
difficulties in changing it?
- Well, curriculum is, first of all,
it was designed in 1890 something,
which was perfectly okay
in 1890 to teach biology.
And after biology, chemistry.
And after chemistry, physics.
It's alphabetically okay.
But it turns out that
in 1890 that was okay.
But in 1930s we made major discoveries,
which show that chemistry and
physics are closely allied.
That there's no phenomenon in chemistry
that doesn't require an explanation
which goes through your
knowledge of physics.
And same thing with biology.
Biology now is the most
complicated of all subjects.
And therefore, it should
wait for an understanding
of physics and chemistry before you tackle
the big subject of biology, and life,
and processes of that kind.
But our schools are not adapting to it.
The old criterion of starting
in 9th grade with biology,
then going to chemistry,
and then going to physics
in the U.S. is done in 92%,
or some number like
that, of all our schools.
And it's out of date.
It's wrong.
It doesn't take into
account all of the knowledge
we've gained in the 20th century
about chemistry, physics, and biology.
They are connected subjects now,
and we have to teach them that way.
Our schools are failing to produce,
not only failing to
produce the kind of quality
and number of dedicated scientists,
to me I'm more worried about
the ignorance of the general public.
What we need is public science literacy.
We need the public to have some
grasp, not to be scientist,
but to have a grasp of how science works.
Because they're gonna vote.
They're going to elect.
They're going to, the
government is gonna seek
their approval for lots of things.
Do we need more nuclear weapons today?
Maybe we don't need any that we have now.
There are many issues in which you need
a public science literacy,
and we don't have it.
We're not producing it
in the high schools.
We're not producing it in the colleges.
And I particularly find
fault with universities
who have a responsibility for
producing educated citizens.
But an educated citizen
has to have a grasp
of what science is, what science can do,
what science cannot do.
And that's where we're failing.
- The changes you were
suggesting yesterday
in your lecture that are required,
one is really involved in
changing the role of the teacher.
When I grew up, one, the
teacher was an authority figure
who passed on, this is the
information that we have.
And you're suggesting really,
we've gotta really overhaul
that notion of the teacher.
- Well, yes, I think.
I mean, and the way I put it
is you wake up one morning
and you're the President
of the United States.
And you won on a mandate
of fixing education.
And the pentagon doesn't know
what to do with all the money.
So you have infinite resources.
What do you do?
The first thing usually you do is
you look at the teacher core.
And there are some
wonderful teachers around.
But the teacher education
is essentially poorly done.
Teachers are not well-educated,
especially in mathematics and science.
So you look at primary school teachers.
It's a disaster.
And that's not only in the U.S.
In most countries primary school teachers
are not trained in math and science,
and yet, small children are eager to know
and learn, and enjoy the beauty,
and the fun of mathematics and science.
It's supposed to be a glorious activity.
It should be fun.
Teachers don't see that.
They're not trained well enough,
especially primary school teachers.
So teacher education
becomes a major thing.
And teacher, it's not
only the pay of teachers,
which is inadequate,
but it's the social status of
teachers, which is inadequate.
So we have to pay attention
to respect of teachers.
In Germany, I think,
a kindergarten teacher's a Frau professor.
We have to give teachers,
and teachers have to earn, respect.
And that doesn't happen.
I've seen, often I'd sit in a classroom
after discussing something with a teacher,
and just as she erases the blackboard,
out comes the loudspeaker saying,
all teachers hand in
their attendance summary.
How dare you interrupt a teacher
in the holy moment of teaching
for some stupidity,
administrative stupidity.
So it show a lack of the kind of respect
we have to have for our teachers.
They have to earn it, but they
have to have that respect.
They have to have the remuneration.
We have to look carefully at
present high school students
for potential teachers,
and glamorize the teachers,
and make more movies about teachers
like famous movie, Dead Poets Society.
We have to embroil the media in elevating
the task of teaching
because that's so crucial
to improving your educational system.
And our system isn't working.
- A third point that I heard you making is
that we have to re-figure
how we teach science,
and in a way draw in
the humanities in a way.
And I think you're suggesting
that story telling,
stories what we think of
in the literature courses,
in a way, have to be brought into science.
So scientist become attractive.
Their stories become attractive.
The steps in there doing
the work become important.
- Yeah, I think the key word is process.
Right now, when we teach science,
let's say even a reasonably good teacher,
and maybe it's 9th grade, 10th grade,
the content of science is taught.
So you learn about
velocity, and acceleration,
and momentum, and energy,
all these things that have
to do with the content.
But there's another aspect to science,
and that's even more important
if we're thinking not
about future scientists
as much as by our future citizens,
future family members who
have to make decisions,
future voters who have to make decisions.
For that, we need to
teach, what is science?
How does it worK?
Does it ever go wrong?
If it goes wrong, how do we fix it?
There are many questions
that have to do with
the process of science rather
than the content of science,
or in addition to the content of science.
So my strong feeling is
that we sacrifice maybe 20%,
or maybe 30% of content for process,
for telling stories
about how science works,
how we made discoveries.
What is a scientist?
How do they grow?
How do they behave?
What makes exciting science?
Is science ever wrong?
If it's wrong, how do we fix it?
Many, many issues that have to do with
the process of science is
part of being educated.
So I'm shocked when college presidents
decide that the science
requirement for this college
will be a semester of what
they call rocks for jocks,
or something.
(laughing)
In a non-serious way.
I actually believe that
University of Chicago,
which is probably more advanced than most,
requires two full years of
science for all its graduates.
You don't graduate from
the University of Chicago
without two full years of science.
One in biological sciences,
the other in physical
sciences with laboratory.
And even that may not be enough to produce
what you would call an educated citizen
who can participate in many decisions.
Now, again, if you go back and look at
all the problems poor Mr. Obama is facing,
all those problems have a science side.
It's not that science
can fix all the problems,
but the knowledge of science is crucial
to these environmental
catastrophe we're facing
even to the failure of our economy.
And you look one after
another at these problems,
and they're not all fixed by science,
but they are all have a role,
science has a role to paly
in repairing our society.
And I think our education
system is not up to it.
That's what we have to do.
We have to really begin to
say that we need a total,
not reform, but transform
nation of the way we teach.
- In your work, and just talking
with you about your career,
one has the sense that you have,
you develop in your work
a sense of the particular,
the little thing that you have to do,
but also at the same time a sense of
the big picture in science.
I'm curious, when you look
at the educational system,
do we fix the whole thing at once,
or is it a step-by-step process?
And if so, what is the first step?
- Now you're over my salary level.
(laughing)
- I see, okay.
- We had some ideas about what to do.
Clearly, if you look at our
system you see where it's wrong.
We have 50 states.
We have 16,000 school districts
and very little communication
between different parts of the country.
I mean, does New Jersey
know what Montana's doing.
And if a poor teacher
goes from one to another,
does she have to learn a new language.
We have this incoherent
array of things now.
I do believe that local
participation is very important.
You just can't shut out the
parents and the local people.
But that doesn't mean that you
can't have better communication.
I think the states have
to organize themselves.
I think the business community should play
an extremely important role in unifying
the different state activities.
There's a business higher
education round table
that issues papers.
There's an enormous
amount of literature out.
They are telling us what's wrong
with our educational
system and how to fix it.
What's missing, what's
missing is a mechanism
for implementing all the good
ideas that are out there.
We're missing an implementation structure,
and that's very important.
Remember when Sputnik.
Well, we had a crisis in Sputnik.
And we needed an organization
that could allow us
to compete with the Soviets in space.
It was called NASA.
So we created NASA before it existed.
We needed that.
In the same way now, I think
we need an organization,
a compact, not administrative,
but really philosophical
group that looks at
the needs of our educational system,
and does all the propaganda,
gets the media involved,
gets the public involved.
We've gotta have an Oprah
Winfrey type of support system
form the public.
If the public is not joining
into this revolution,
it won't work.
We've gotta get the public.
We've gotta explain to the general public
why it's so important that
our educational system
be brought into the 21st century.
That's where we are.
- One final question
looking back on your career,
is there a piece of
advice, one piece of advice
that you would give students out there
who might wanna become scientists,
or citizens out there who wanna become
more scientifically informed?
- Well, I think the advice is,
I think that the public has
to be aware of the problem.
And the public has to be realistic.
I mean, too often, parents charge in
without knowing enough about
what it is that has to be done.
And I've seen this sometimes
with disastrous results.
So we need a sympathetic public.
And what we need is leading
citizens that might take
advise, and lead, and cajole, and so on.
Because if the public
really gets upset now,
and begins to understand the repercussions
of a failed education system,
and the things we have to do to fix it,
if they don't get involved
in this nothing will happen.
So we need public leadership,
people who can lead.
And certainly, we've
never been, in my memory,
as well off as we are now in Washington
with gifted leadership.
But unfortunately, we
have so many problems,
one on top the other, that
may frustrate the great power
that we now, in principle,
could bring to bear on the problem.
- And what about advice to
students who wanna be scientists?
- Well, that's, it's a wonderful career.
I mean, the main thing about science
that people ought to be aware
of is how much fun it is
and how beautiful it is.
And the joy of doing
science is something that
more scientist should not be
embarrassed about extolling.
I mean, it's fun.
Sometimes you're looking for
somebody in a science building,
and there's noise, and
you suddenly realize
there are three or four scientist.
They're rolling on the floor laughing.
Why are they laughing?
Well, they just worked for
three years on some subject,
and they couldn't solve it.
And all of a sudden, they solved it.
And the solution was so
simple and so beautiful
that they just burst into laughter.
I think that joy of science
is there if you work at it.
It's fun, it's beautiful,
and it's profitable.
- Dr. Lederman, I wanna
thank you very much
for taking the time to share
your experiences with us today.
Thank you very much.
And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(upbeat techno music)